you could be back in town I just got
back from visiting a friend of mine in
Chicago any Chicago lovers great town
just so many mustaches uh you know what
the best part of the whole trip was
being the guy from out of town I love
that I love being the guy from out of
town because your friends in that town
have to show out-of-town guy a good time
that's the rule it's almost biblical you
got to be like ready the baths and
prepare our finest ball
we don't want Peter returning to Los
Angeles thinking Judea was kinda lame is
there anything better than that as a
friend
grabbing and handing you a beer that
they only microbrew in that neighborhood
whispering like I'm gonna show you the
real Chicago that's the best unless
you're in Cincinnati in which case call
911 having a stroke very close to zero
on that one how do you like if we don't
laugh no more strokes what I'm saying is
when you have a local to show around
you're not some schmuck tourists and
cargo shorts wearing a fanny pack stuff
with traveler's checks and sunblock
rocking a nikon camera around your neck
like it's a Rick Ross medallion your
duck boat tour guide reciting general
information he's reading off of Google
just like Chicago is the Windy City that
no you got the real hookup and it's
totally free of charge you're seeing the
insider stuff talking around the back
streets like you know if you go and
Wrigley Field this way they let you play
shortstop
and like this is the pizza place where
Al Capone shot a clown your local
friends take you to sample all the food
you can't get anywhere else
that's a big our town thing let me show
you the food you can't get nowhere else
which is always just some variation of a
hotdog
like here and shite down your throats
out the bun dip both ends of the wiener
and ketchup like Darth Maul's lightsaber
one shake a soft on the GOG dew on a
picture Harry Caray boom Chicago dog I
don't care that's the local experience
you get to see all the bars I'm talking
about the real bars not the ordinary
tourists loading into some chain bar and
grill they have and every we're taking
pictures of the TGI Fridays sign because
the tea's wearing a Cubs hat now you're
pulling up to a seemingly abandoned
building that's actually a beach themed
bar with sand on the floor they hand you
a free slice of deep-dish Hawaiian pizza
just for walking in Midwestern hostess
just like welcome to the ham and sand
gentlemen my name is Pam p.m. at the
Hammond cien yeah after the ham and sand
you go out for drinks but not even at a
bar you go to your buddy's buddy's house
now you're drinking on a roof and not
like a flat roof like some fancy hotel
party like Snoopy's doghouse style
leaning against a chimney rolling your
empties down hoping they land in that
empty kiddie pool you're pretty sure
it's him - that's real livin people
climbing in and out of windows like Zack
Morris visiting Jesse in the earlier
seasons
that's a night out that's not in the
guidebooks
the only thing better than being the guy
from out of town is when you get to host
the guy from out of town in your town
even if it's a boring town because it's
your responsibility to make it fun don't
phone it in like a dick
just like dye this place yeah that's
chubs
who cares chubs it's been there 97 years
they got a drink called the chub chub
it's just sprite with a lemon and the
lime and two cherry cider I don't care
show him Chuck
give him the real experience chubbs is
the real version of your town they want
to see chubbs
don't be a stingy buy around a chump
chubbs you're slow even if your town is
lame it's still fun to show people
around you get to be the local historian
driving them all over the place pointing
out every detail just like this Lake
didn't used to be this full yep never
been fuller it's the rain fall they say
funny thing lakes take him to the mall
just an ordinary mom but you have all
the insider info like oh yeah this is
where I had my first job at the
Nordstrom Rack speaking of racks that's
the cinnamon where I felt up Gina's
Palermo she gave me a free sample okay
that is that's ridiculous